[Music]
so I'm standing on the shoulders of
others right now but also it's like it's
gonna be one of the most well-attended
well for the nominees we've got the
whole house nominees coming and we've
got a bunch of directors making a hot
tailing it from uh from the dgas
um we've even had to you know what what
you did some some categories are
slightly further down the schedule to
make sure that people can get anything
so nowhere tonight then it's a real
Testament but you know so much people
not just the Bronson Europeans but so
many people
[Music]
yeah yeah the top of the show is very
enjoyable and Richard is um
that'd be great yeah
[Music]
you're right
really nice
questions
[Music]
um
thank you
sorry baby
[Music]
um
yourself
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
thank you
guys are you guys on TV yes yes
in 20 minutes
[Music]
any interest
it's like a very quick photo
yes
yeah they're great friends together
not here
okay
[Music]
um
foreign
situations
[Music]
definition for all the problems
sure
[Music]
well I mean the film is is
um
[Music]
in the music videos
um
it's wonderful I mean you know when you
do a movie from your of your own country
because I've done quite a couple of
English and American movies and but
doing one in your own language
it is different it has a different let's
say attachments to your to your own
upbringing to your childhoods
let's say to all those historical things
that I learned from my parents and
um and then working on something that I
really appreciate and then getting
recognition this is like you know you
never you never hope I would say you
always you know you do your best and
then suddenly all these recognitions are
popping up which is amazing it is such a
an emotional film to watch so one that
really does kind of bring you into the
heart and what it must have felt things
about them and it was important for you
I guess to to let the stories speak to
itself as well not to kind of play with
anyone with emotions too much no I think
when you look at the film I think it's a
film for everyone you know because it
plays with uh with a young group of with
a group of young boys that are in the
way by Propaganda get led into a mistake
in a way that costs all of them their
life and when you when you watch the
movie or when I watched it the first
time I was so um emotionally touched but
not in a way that I felt about War I was
more about thinking about my own life
and you're thinking about how what what
you want to do so I think there's also a
kind of religious aspect because it's
talking about how are you making life
decisions and who are you believing
you know so and of course war is is not
working at all you know and in the end
when you when you leave her when you are
getting out of the screening there is
this need of talking to other people and
you know we we need that we need
conversation we need getting
understanding for others like empathy
you know so I think in a way the film
has a lot of
um
it can actually lead to a lot of
positive things well what we're saying
you're leading nominations tonight for
you then I guess is it just important
that a lot of people are talking about
the film then anymore
well I mean for me it's just uh you know
you never you never think about getting
a rewards it's much more than I felt
when you were at the Toronto Film
Festival
felt there's some strength in the film
and so in a way that everyone around me
is also knowing it is so nice because we
all can talk about I meet actually all
the different departments which I
normally don't meet I mean I'm and I'm
touring with them like a band
you know through the world and we sit
sometimes at The Breakfast Table we talk
about what was your experience and you
don't have that with let's say with a
hair and makeup Department you never
meet them because they are in the shoes
you know and as a composer you don't
meet them because you are so much later
in it but once you you hear their
stories suddenly the whole the whole
film makes sense because we felt
suddenly that every Department was
working so well together that it felt
like a like a film that was you know a
complete how can I say that every
Department was in the way going through
the same direction
yes yes which which you don't have every
every time
[Music]
thank you very much
excited
hello hello
congratulations thank you
guys it feels a long way from from
Temple Patrick where we shot this film
that's for sure in the the mud in the
markets um it's it's nice to be out here
and they're dressed up to the nines
we're having the time of our lives I'll
be honest with you yeah
yeah so an Irish Dubai is a short-term
following these two kind of Australians
brothers and sure flung back together
after the untimely death of their mum
and they sort of had this gracious
relationship Logan who plays the younger
brother as sort of Milestone syndrome
and there's this added layer of sort of
care responsibility and then they
discover their mums on people's bucket
list and that kind of slowly brings them
back together as they try to complete
every item off that list on behalf there
I mean when you were making this did you
dare to kind of dream that you would be
hearing the whole season being one of
those no I don't think we allowed
ourselves that kind of distress action
um I think though when we brought James
and Sheamus who played the brothers
together for the first time in
rehearsals and just hearing the stories
of them face climbing in the evenings
doing their running their lines and then
they learned their lives They carried on
face timing in the evenings because they
just got on so well I think at that
point we realized that there was
something special with them as actors
and their performances but we just
wanted the film to get eyeballs and get
out there and you know to end up here
but it's the it's icing on cherry on top
of everything I mean not just bastards
Austin
yeah I mean that's another silly one
it's I mean these are just silly rooms
to be a part of it's just like these are
the people you've worked off to your
whole life as a filmmaker you know and
to be sort of rubbing shoulders we were
at this luncheon at the Oscars we met
Steven Spielberg and that's on cruise I
would say we spoke to Tom Cruise I think
Tom Cruise spoke to us and we stood
there like uh uh
Top Gun very good so yeah it's been very
surreal we're slowly acclimatizing but
yeah very soon
I don't even
I mean when he was our age he was making
Jaws so you know it yeah well you think
you're doing Steven's always there so
yeah he uh
yeah I think when you start you know in
short film at the end we were just as
emerging filmmakers I suppose we just
wanted to create a portfolio of work
again people could show people the kind
of you never think that this is going to
happen at the end of it it's just I'm
just so proud of everybody that works in
the film is so pleased that this is kind
of giving it a whole other life and you
know introducing it to a much wider
audience because I think the guys are
fantastic in the film and yeah we love
watching it you know you don't often
love watching your work back sometimes
you know you see the flaws in it but
this one I just I do I just love
watching it and I love their work
[Music]
foreign
okay it's good and then when you see the
end result and you're Blown Away by what
has just happened yeah and you hope that
everybody else has been entertained by
it and you know what and it has it
hasn't at the end everyone and there's
no not too many bad words being said
about it so we're very very close
amazing and so what's the biggest
misconception about Awards season so far
for you guys
um I suppose people ask you know when
you've met people that you've actually
had a proper conversation with them but
our experience is when we get along in
front of I mean I think the first person
that was Tom Cruise we didn't say it
worked and then we just couldn't make
sounds happen out of our mouths we just
stood there and kind of stung silence
and he was very good with us when he
spoke to us yeah he spoke to us so I say
we've had conversations with these
people who are really really happy we've
just been in their bread you still
didn't listen
lovely words he did say so that's great
so who's in the film he hadn't seen the
buildings but he was giving us some tips
about how to do it all and he said look
just soak it all in you know enjoy it
you're in the room now just welcome and
really have a good day this was back to
lunch at the Oscars so yeah I think
we're gonna try and do that tonight
we're not too worried about whatever
happens we're just gonna enjoy it eat
Tom Cruise's advice what a strange
sentence to say
that's amazing have a great time
thank you pleasure thank you very much
thank you very much
[Music]
um
okay
[Music]
foreign
that's a great question I think I mean
really what it all started with from
Dana Daniel when I first came onto the
project was it was just a place of pure
kind of love and expression and wanting
to spread empathy in the world and what
they didn't know was that the world in
2020 was going to go through what it
went through and I think we all needed
that we all needed something positive
and a kind of collective catharsis that
a film gives us the Multiverse Madness
it's an editor of course for you to kind
of deal with the sort of craziness
you're showing on the screen is this a
project that was incredibly unique
challenge oh yeah it was a huge
challenge it was incredibly intimidating
when I first script but you know I had
great captains and guides and Daniel
scheiner and Dan Quan and they really
just it was all in their head it was the
you know the script was beautiful the
performances were incredible and uh it
was challenging but it was the funnest
challenge of my life I mean I got to I
had a job during lockdown which was
great and I got to work with my best
friends making something really
beautiful so it was wonderful about the
Daniels and their Vision the people are
sort of captured people's imaginations I
mean they're they're big children they
really are they just you spend any time
with them they're just pure energy and
enthusiasm and ideas and they they come
from a pure place of really wanting to
make something good for the world do
they want to make a good film that's you
know aesthetically beautiful and
challenging but they also want to make
work that does good for the world and
that's I think that attracts an
incredible amount of talent to them if
they're your friends as well for any
moments when you're making this when
you've sort of said hot dog fingers you
know they're reading the script I was
like sorry reading the script I was like
you know this is um this is gonna be in
the wrong hands this could be a disaster
but I trusted them I knew that they had
a plan they have this beautiful ability
to take something silly and make it
beautiful and uh to take something
beautiful and make it silly as well and
uh and so I totally trusted them
thank you so much
I just woke up from my voice cracks I
have bad uh layovers
[Music]
they are but they're on their way so I
think they'll fly in halfway through the
ceremony so you know they'll sure
they'll be in great forms
[Music]
they're excited yeah they're excited and
it's an excuse to hang out I mean they
finished this film right as Lockdown kit
so we never had a wrap party so all of
these things are our kind of collective
wrap parties
I don't know
I think writing the thing is the hard
part I mean one of these ideas came from
is a mystery to me I'm so glad that it
came out of them but I have no idea
uh but they're they're wonderful and
kind and empathetic and you know that
kind of wonderful
insanity is what attracts all these
other insane people into their Broadways
foreign
[Music]
thank you
right excuse me Disney for grown-ups
congratulations on the denominations
it's so special and it's special because
the award is special it's special
because the previous nominees are
special and the current nominees and
because the projects that I'm loving it
for is special as well so it's great
[Music]
yeah yeah and you know what more so I
was proud of everyone during the making
of it you know before it was even a
final product because I could literally
see the work that was happening
alongside me and whatever the final
products ended up being I knew everyone
had really genuinely put their blood
foot into his literal Blood Sweat into
his into this film so for me it was
already you know it was already a
transformative experience it was
exhausting to be a part
there's kind of no other way to yeah it
was it was an accurate but uh it had to
be you know like we were portraying
these like crazy female warriors who
just they fought their foot and they you
know they went through unimaginable
things to be the best they could be so
we had to kind of try and move into the
same
it's a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah I
should probably get back in the gym
though I'm not gonna lie like it's been
a little minute and I'm like oh
struggling upstairs
[Music]
you know it is what it is like I think
for me the really important I need to
remind myself before our whole team to
remind ourselves of what we did because
what we did Israel you know and the
prospect of awards it's not in our hands
ultimately we just do our best we do our
best work and we hope that it impacts
people when it moves people so that's
what we've done you know and then when
it comes to the surrounding aspects of
the industry like Awards you know they
will all wherever they need to go and
hopefully changes will happen when they
happen but I'm happy I'm so happy and
I'm so proud of all of us and that for
me is my main focus
I just kind of want to be a Disney
princess a little bit like that's maybe
it's like a dress like this today to
like you know give a nod to it but I
think it'd be nice as well a bit of a
change I tend to do a lot of like you
know heavier dramas and maybe something
where I get to you know see and kind of
sing-along tune and look wistfamily over
the river
okay good thank you thank you cheers
sorry
um I think these guys are going to come
here okay
[Music]
it needs just to Assurance of
um
so I did this and it sounds so bizarre
but somehow it gave me something to
direct the line towards and and I mean
in the end it worked I wouldn't try it
with other directors just the tip moving
forward with your career yes and we were
like yeah
yeah it's completely different this is
this really reflects uh Guillermo and
Patrick the other screenwriters the new
sort of twist on the story I think it
really makes it worth telling again
yeah it's just great in it
it's so great I mean it's it really is a
tribute to all of the artists who work
on this because it takes hundreds of
people to you know these puppets take a
year to make I think and then you don't
realize everything it's so complex
there's so many artists and they're all
just brilliant
[Music]
it was like so relieving because it was
like three years of anticipation I I
started the recording when I was nine or
ten and now I'm 13.
um so seeing it all went into one piece
with all the incredible Works done by
the team as Mark said and it's just like
such a satisfying and awesome thing to
see yeah
[Music]
yeah
it's like it's it means so much it
really means so much it's always you
know winning Awards is the lovely day
one of these nominated for awards is a
lovely thing but in conjunction with the
projects that you really care about
makes it that bit more special so yeah
I'm so happy to be able to
representative
and I thought well that's everything
[Music]
thank you
uh yeah I mean he's got to be pretty uh
pretty pricey though it is yeah it's
probably about as expensive as a car you
drove here in today wow they're not
cheap these puppets take a long time to
make yeah
[Music]
um
you know really think it's the strong
themes of the Betrayal of a youthful
generation and that is important now as
ever and it's kind of doesn't matter
which country it's about in many ways
but of course seeing it from what we
know is the enemy's perspective is is
really powerful
that German sensibility
and we also wanted to have something
that wasn't in the book which was
unavailable to remark and that was
historical context so we added in that
original 2007. uh the uh
getting a lot of attention I think it's
like a
so we feel that these awards are
important to spread The Voice
I've been in this crazy and fancy places
with friends it feels better so we're
having fun
the biggest misconception is that you
need to work a lot
but it's uh yeah it's like talking
repeating the same things all the time
too many months but still is fun and
it's a great opportunity and we know
it's like for us for a South American
Film it's not probably not many times
that you have the chance to do it so we
are enjoying it okay
a lot a lot and that was the best
have the pleasure to see the film with
different peoples of society and to
everyone is the same so it's crazy the
response was really good and we we are
really honored that we're we're having a
good time thank you very much
[Music]
um
season
thank you very much
can we talk to you just quickly
did it feel very important when you get
it right I guess as well yes of course I
mean you have you have seen the two
other versions that were done in the 30s
and the 70s
you uh read the book and you know it's
the most printed German novel on the
planet and now you have the chance and
the responsibility to bring this story
to screen for another time
and that's just
uh quite quite a responsibility to have
on your shoulders
yes it did it feels it felt very
realistic we you know you get told a lot
of stories about the sets but then you
finally arrive there and you see a
hundred twenty thousand square meters of
mugs and trenches
and suddenly you are in it and that's
unbelievable I read one of the
things we all weren't tears it was I I
guess it wasn't the scene in the in the
crater
and it was a collective morning for
hours because it was just so hard for
all of us to go through that over and
over and over again
mean regardless of whether you come away
with 14 wins tonight are you just
incredibly proud of how the response has
been absolutely I'm absolutely proud of
this whole process and this journey of
the movie took
um it's my very first movie ever so I'm
super excited to
to experience all of that
yes of course
very important yeah because I mean we
are doing a film not just for
entertainment but maybe to show the
world what is going on and what we
should really think about so that's
maybe something to think about nice to
meet you Felix best of luck thank you
thank you
to get these combinations
[Music]
supported
yes of course
Danielle could like wrapping quickly as
well Katie from Sky News
um
no it's really amazing I'm really proud
about it for the changes that they've
made over the last couple years
um because as we know it's just been
tough for women to have our work valued
in the same way so Props the bathroom
I'm really proud to have this nomination
yeah I mean we have to talk about the
Oscars as well so many people saying why
aren't you in the running for an Oscar
as well has that been deeply frustrating
for you I'm think I think angering is
probably a better word but but it's not
just about me it's about a systemic
issue that's been there
um again I'm really hoping that the
Oscars take a look at what bafta has
done because the changes have really
worked and I think that's what we need
to do I mean it's an adult conversation
we're talking about the lack of black
actresses as well that are up for it and
Andrew arrives but who is the dominators
were saying that she Mouse has seen that
there is systemic inequality that exists
within the film industry yeah would you
agree with that oh 100 I mean perhaps
Andrea for recognizing that and speaking
out about it that's what it's going to
take not just for us who are the
casualties happen to speak up but for
others to speak up and so Props to her
for doing that so you how special a film
was this to work on does it is it all
the better to get recognition here about
this experience was such a profound
experience to be able to tell this film
with this group of actors
um I don't know how I'll ever have
something that feels as good again I
hope so but uh yeah it's a special film
and we're really proud of him well we
hope to see you nominated for an Oscar
in the next few years at least
brilliant nice to meet you thank you
foreign
[Music]
recognize the talent behind it I'm proud
that they've made to make it more of a
meritocracy
[Music]
from our families
and having the best time I am I so we we
brought her into I am leaning in I'm
about you know at the beginning of the
season of shiny things when the first
swirling of all of it happened with that
one right there
I said I have two choices I can either
go like this
like no no no no no no no no no no I
don't no don't say it I don't want to
hear or I can go yeah yeah great bring
it like I'm open
you have two choices be opened or closed
and I I'm old enough and then Show
Business long enough that I chose to be
open
refreshing it is refreshing because you
are genuinely enjoying this circuit
you're enjoying the possibility of
winning prizes you know what it's funny
now that I've gotten to know all of the
nominees and all the categories because
of the way they group us and I don't
care smiling
I will tell you Tuesday morning
uh February 24th not February 24th yes
no today's been uh let's read the 19th
February no no what date was the the
sixth Oscars no the date that they
announced I can't even remember
Oscars January January Tuesday
I will tell you that Tuesday January
24th at 5 35 in the morning
was the win
like I that I don't care
to be included
in this institution and this institution
to be a nominee in this house
is the wind
the rest are TV shows and horse races
and I'm I'm you know I I just have no
comment but to be here with you as a
nominee at the Baptist history
honestly I am just so thrilled to be
here isn't it great to see everything
everywhere so so normally received by so
many people so many nominations so it's
it's just that again it's that sort of
Miracle thing that happens nobody can
understand it it's it's art and timing
and covid and we now it was one of the
first movies in wide release where we
were safe to go back in the theaters and
it was a movie about something and it
isn't trivial and it isn't silly and
stupid it's about love
family and immigrants it's an immigrant
story and there aren't a lot of those
and a reunification of a broken family a
broken marriage a broken daughter and
mother it's exquisite
it's Exquisite and deeply moving and
asks us who are we why are we here what
are we about
and that to me is the thrill of that
movie I mean when you made a smile as
well we need that and there were great
laughs but in the midst of it all it
also cracked you open crack me open when
Keith Juan says can't we just be kind
and sobbing sobbing sobbing sobbing in
the theater add Tiff
the I saw it in a movie theater at a
premiere for the first time
sobbing sobbing sobbing
I so hope you win tonight I want to see
what you say on stage that's sobbing
sobbing saw me thank you thank you so
much
say the Daniels clearly absolute
creative Geniuses but when you're
reading a script and it says hot dog
fingers that was the moment I will tell
you
I'm getting a good picture we have
priorities do you get it okay good
um I will tell you that reading the
script
that was the moment where I was like
is that going to work what's that going
to look like because it could have been
a force it could have been
a really silly world and I just didn't
know and what we found emotionally
Michelle and and me and the Daniels
was anything but silly it was deeply
moving and and heartbreaking because
it's about
their entire relationship
from beginning to end and ends of
relationships are heartbreaking
they wanted to have a Michelle was that
the well I said yes because Michelle yo
was in the movie I mean that's just the
truth and then my agent said we should
read it
and I was like no it's okay I'll do it
and he said no no I think you should
read it
he says it's a little out there I'm like
okay I'll read it whatev and I read it
and then it was like oh
wow it's extraordinary
well I I never I have won a bafta uh
when I was 21 years old 22 for trading
places but I flew in for the day like
I'm doing here but I didn't know
anything I didn't know what the Baptists
were I barely knew who I was I barely I
borrowed a dress some guy makes my hair
all puffy like and then I won and that
was insane
now I'm a grown-up I'm 64 years old I've
been nominated for things before and
I've lost them I've been nominated for
things before and I've won them I
haven't been nominated for things for a
long time it's part of my job
it's a hard business
I never the way I deal with the business
is I just I'm like this
[Music]
I don't want to know and then I'm not
then the business doesn't crush me
because it can be crushing
when I heard my name on Oscar morning
there was a picture of me that my friend
took where I'm in abject shop because it
was never something I thought would
happen the bath does when Heidi called
me and said the bafta nominations came
in again now I know what everything is
but my perspective is I'm just so happy
I'm happy to be here I'm happy
representing a beautiful movie happy
representing women my age happy being in
an industry that usually kicks women out
and here I am is absolutely brilliant
film we're all rooting you thank you
aren't you lovely thank you so much God
bless you everyone stay safe
[Music]
correspondences
thank you
yeah
um
we have the same problems
foreign
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
a Lexi's daughter
it's very exciting I'm
um you know it's it's a weird feeling
being here and him being imprisoned but
you know I'm here to represent the
family I'm here to represent the
anti-corruption foundation and they're
doing amazing work and I'm very happy
that the movie got nominated it's an
honor is he aware of the nomination yes
absolutely he's aware of the bafta and
the Oscar and he told us to tell him all
about it in the letters that we're able
to send
how important was it for you that they
sort of explained his position in a way
that really sort of people understood
what the situation was I mean we were
all concerned about something well
um the documentary turned out amazing
I'm very happy with our incredible and
talented team and I'm just
I'm very happy that the workers that
they have been doing for a long time
that my dad's been doing is not going
unnoticed so it's just I'm very I'm very
humbled
and where what's the situation with your
dad at the moment what do we think
anything might change
well currently he's in a solitary
confinement and it's you know he's his
health is not the best but we're trying
to get doctors to him and trying to make
it as
much capable as possible to pass the
time a constant pace of having to kind
of push on people to write absolutely
the the person system in Russia is
horrible you know you don't want to be
in prison overall but the Russian prison
system is terrible and they're
constantly you know saying to the
attorneys that you can't have an
attorney-client meeting or
um saying that you're not available to
meet the doctor because there's too many
patients but there's no one in there you
know it's it's crazy but
we're managing special that people are
recognizing this then here at the baftas
and the Oscars exactly at least raising
away exactly exactly it's very important
to raise up awareness uh tell people
that we're actually fighting against
spoons ranging inside the country
thank you so much
misrepresentation yeah and you've made a
real breakthrough of course last year
expected
I think we're making a movement to the
right trash
it's an interesting characters
we have the people in the door open
right so I'm so grateful for my
accomplishments of my achievement
because I'm the first of anything I will
not be the last
like this year's been amazing to see
everyone Embrace everything everywhere
especially like I'm a big fan but I love
that diversity does seem to be raining
and I think it's really important
because
right now
um
[Music]
it's interesting I mean I'm a member of
the academy so being sent into that I
think I would have loved to see those
women
most beautiful performances over here in
my opinion
I'm very happy about it
being celebrated in the way the
businesses
we've been talking about it
Ariana congratulations on your win last
year thank you good to see you again I
remember your face yeah yeah
you're giving us a song this year I am
giving you a little performance very
excited about it it's all about
celebrating women the accomplishments of
women this year and empowering the
people that are watching at home you are
Limitless don't like do not put limits
on yourself embrace your possibilities
and own how Fierce you are and how
powerful you are and it'll be a party
and if we get we can it's oh I can I'm
so grateful to be able to just cheer
everyone on but I'm excited hopefully
people will get on their feet and party
with me and we'll have a great night
what do you make of the field this year
if you watching the films that stood out
so so many I mean to be frank it's a
really intriguing and I use the word
diverse a lot but it is a diverse array
of filmmaking
um I I love good luck to you Leo Grand
everything everywhere all at once the
fablements like I'm I'm just a fan of
everything and I want to shout out all
the women that are nominated in
outstanding debut their producers their
directors they're writers and I think
that's really heartening as well every
single one of those projects from Blue
Jean on and on is it's really something
different and it moves the needle
forward so I'm really happy to see them
recognized tonight
speech last year you spoke about the
importance of representation and what
you'll win meant to you it's important
we're talking particularly with the
Oscars about within the best actress
category the lack of black actors
actresses
just is there still a long way to go I
think we're moving forward let's not
confuse forward movement with progress I
think we make games and then we gotta
learn from them but it's a pendulum
swing if I'm being very Frank but that
doesn't mean we get to sit back and Pat
ourselves on the back for Progress right
we have to keep going keep moving
forward keep pushing those boundaries
while I would have loved to see those
women in that category I am absolutely
celebrating the women that have been
nominated because they are Stellar
performances in their own right so I
think there has to be room for everyone
and as long as we stay tuned in and keep
our eyes open we can make necessary
changes and make it even more Equitable
than it already is
I hope we love look forward to hearing
you on stage then oh thank you
good lovely how are you good yeah
[Music]
and we're gonna open the show with a
little kitty
boots and um have a really good time
yeah I'm feeling free with him
well sorry
goes to Paris well look I mean there's
phenomenal outfits in that then I mean
congratulations thank you very much
nominations how does it feel to be here
again for the bastards but it's
absolutely lovely and I think the really
lovely thing is that such a small low
budget film and yes it is about props so
that's fun but but we got noticed you
know amongst the titans of the big films
so if this is particularly thrilling
this year I have to be honest more than
um in a way well I mean they're at toys
I don't want to be rude anywhere about
any of my nominations but actually it's
particularly threading this year
and just wants it and the whole story is
how she gets it but then when she gets
to Paris eventually
um you know she manages to change lives
and well it's simple positive glorious
hard-working attitude and it's one of
those feel-good films you haven't seen
honestly it's really joyous and Leslie
Manda is phenomenal
I love being in London
I do I love the atmosphere I love the
sense of community so I don't know if I
took helps you right back it's nice that
you said that they have a really good
website and I'm one of the doctor voters
actually so that's all of our main
things
um
I inclusivity absolutely at inclusivity
yeah and there is a fair assessment of
the work I don't think that the word
necessarily has to be popular at the box
office doesn't necessarily have to have
the big names I think that you just look
at the work I really do and I love the
fact that the Rising Star Award the
public they vote on that that's huge you
know I love it
um obviously you're out throwing aboard
here tonight it didn't happen at the
Oscars that was the big stink wasn't it
are you over that now Audrey is it just
like this is something we've really got
to sort out because that's what
everyone's saying
okay okay
all right fair enough okay okay
one quick question yeah right here yes
yes okay here
well it's just an acknowledgment of the
work that that's what you want at the
end of the day yes do you want
popularity the box office do you want
people to come up to you ad nauseum
after the film and tell you how much you
move them and all of that we as artists
and there was a lot of female artists
and artists of color working on that
film we want to be acknowledged for our
skill for our Excellence for our craft
these are people who've been out there
for years decades doing what they do
um and not getting noticed and so yeah
that's what it means to be at the
Baptist
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry just one moment
[Music]
okay great
foreign
okay
yeah yeah both it's a boyfriend's family
[Music]
girls names
foreign
thank you
um
by today
so I called
I thought this was a hunger for original
[Music]
franchises that are little movies to
sneak in there and then it's just such a
big audience and then we do Awards you
know it is a dream come true
foreign
you want
yes
nice to see you Hillary you're looking
gorgeous
yeah I'll tell you where I got it one
day one day
it was probably shoot that somebody left
it behind I was like I love that oh my
God that's genius it's so cheap
wow
I think
[Music]
it doesn't look like
early on from watching rashes and
realizing how good the channel is going
to be and I realizing how good Alicia
was going to be I I knew
between the chemistry it's really
something special I thought we might be
able and then that's important stuff
obviously
okay
I was stuck in Australia and couldn't be
there but I only got to meet a lot of
the cast when I came to the opening in
the London film festival and so that's
yeah they're pretty amazing
factors
for me and it's amazing she is
incredible and yeah like most
controversies these days it's beating us
so um yeah we've got to get very good at
just ignoring it and the media needs to
get better at ignoring that yeah
tonight you were the best British film
there's a quite a little scrum showing
oh we're gonna rump it in family films
always win baptisms
great to see you too thank you quick
question
it's very very cool to be nominated and
such an amazing year of gorgeous films
and I just feel you know like the cat
who got the cream or some crassa
metaphor I you know I wrote these songs
14 years ago and this film which I
wasn't very involved in because I was
stuck in Australia in covert
um I just got to watch it I got to watch
all the rushes all the raw footage
coming coming down the line and it's
just been stunning and I'm very proud of
everyone involved if you've had any
nerves the casting surely in itself must
have yeah that was when I realized how
special it was going to be is I mean
obviously Emma Thompson you know you're
gonna get an earth-shattering
performance but I didn't really know
lashana's work except from sort of
Marvel Universe and stuff and obviously
no one had ever heard of Alicia uh but
watching those two actors playing Miss
honey and Matilda in their chemistry and
when I first saw bits of um Miss Honey's
songs and I just thought this is going
to make people sob and laugh and yeah
it's been great
oh I have absolutely zero expectations
I'm I'm thrilled to be here I've flown
all the way from Australia to sort of be
a part of it and um I don't think uh
family musicals are usually what bapta
voters vote for but I I do regardless of
what happens
feature live action feature musicals at
this scale I mean there hasn't been one
like it in decades it's a really special
thing and we're already winners because
it's being watched by hundreds of
millions of people so I'm very very
proud to be here yeah thank you
[Music]
nominated this year
together
isn't on the menu tonight but I'm here
to support Phil and Danielle Detweiler
and with all these amazing talented
people
get an announcement because honestly
there's another example
imagine how I feel yeah it'll be a while
we have a lot of work to do before we
start
cast that's what we need to know we're
on the case
future
[Music]
very exciting it's a bit crazy at the
moment so kind of nervous but yeah it's
exciting
it's a real time when we have yet to
find out how to get into great fashion
yes definitely yes
[Music]
like outside
yeah we were shooting for six weeks and
we had two weeks to get to know each
other and throw each other in the pool
yeah it's not you're not thinking about
this moment never I don't think I'd be
worried to hear someone say that they
were while they're making the film but
do you hope that you're making something
special I think you have to have belief
in what you're doing to
I don't know what to inspire the people
around you so give as much as you're
required to give in making a film so I
think that was like a shared belief on
all of our part so long is not only
nominated he was just nominated for an
Oscar as well I mean yeah
how it's going to be over there and yeah
I mean like we were both I think on the
phone to him within minutes of the uh
was an IX school we tried to call you
yeah we were both on the phone and we
tried to call you but yeah your mum said
you were in school I would have came
home from typical out to be honest but
then you spoke to him later on right
it's crazy but really cool and I mean
not really bothered a magnificent skill
I'll be honest
it's very nice to meet you both best of
luck today thank you so much
[Music]
anyways
um
yeah let me figure out exactly yeah
foreign
thank you
hello good thank you bouncing around a
little bit with Angela Bassett
um she's the person I'm here to see so
please bring her over
I've just actually posted in the work
group chat that I can see I'm in javasa
from here
you guys are AP and Sky yes okay perfect
I know that's how it works right
she's so excited I'm so glad she's here
she really is
[Music]
I started watching him I started
watching uh 911
and then I had to stop up with the first
two episodes because yeah
foreign
thank you
um
where I talked out a good chance
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
as we're here in the end of the battles
um
is
right now okay
well they do okay all right thank you
Angela congratulations on the nomination
both here and and for the Oscar as well
um we spoke to you yesterday and you
said that there's been years where you
sort of thought you might be nominated
and missed out and and it didn't happen
how does it feel now to be at this
it feels really really incredible so I'm
very pleased very happy about it I'm
excited
special film to work on you've reduced
everyone to tears
what was the important thing for you
this was such just such a beautiful
moment and certainly a highlight of my
career you know the individuals the
pastor crew the director you know
um of this movie this time around you
know um and and also in the memory and
and for the legacy of Chadwick who who
just led us along this journey from the
beginning and his Spirit remains with us
even while we're filming wakanda it just
means a great deal you know it's a film
a headline by by strong beautiful and
talented women you know Leticia Wright
who's one of your own here from UK and
and others as well so it's been just
really really very special and very
poignant
feel like Faith just some sometimes this
is your year this is the stars are
lining you know sometimes if you hang in
there and you you stay in love with that
which you you know are passionate about
you have you have a great chance of
winding up on a you know a bright stage
bright and wonderful stage but uh you
also have the greatest time on the
journey
thank you
are you ready
oh yes yes I'm very honored today
yeah so I'm just wearing this video it
must be really beautiful particularly
this year to see you know the film
recognize your film recognized it must
be poignant they just wait all those
things
foreign
hi
who's that did it yeah
[Music]
foreign
actually
what happens
I guess maybe I haven't been working so
hard
but things are very sweet
so what would it mean to you to get a
victory here tonight
oh I I truly believe that everything
happens
in my past and when I do it's like we
have 10 nominations we are winners all
right good luck tonight
Michelle Katie from the sky news from
the Chatters are generally occur
and she was saying that she's just
having the absolute time of her life
with this and for her stage of her
career she just thought older actresses
she was lucky to even be getting a part
of that stage in her career she felt I
mean has it been a similar thing for you
but too often you're kind of written off
I know I don't know
but it is very true what she was saying
I think in the last few years it becomes
more and more apparent that if you were
to just sit and wait for the roles for
older women to appear if you're going to
wait for the very next time and I think
some of us have taken upon ourselves to
be good writers with storytellers you
reach out to them and say come on guys
there's there's room and definitely
older women need to have their stories
told look at Jane Fonda look at Lily
Tomlin you know and the ones who are
going to be at that that age and when
someone says oh they're past their part
hell no we're going to show you what
prime is right I mean
exactly exactly so what it is is like
you know I think for Jamie and myself we
love what we meet with ourselves we are
passionate about our work so when and
it's almost like it's okay as long as I
get to do what I love it's you know
getting nominated or getting award would
be ultimate but if you don't you know
you sort of resign to it and go yeah
we'll we'll move on we'll we'll find
something as long as we can do what we
love whatever it is okay just finally
the Daniels just have this this crazy
Vision don't they when you were reading
the script hot dog fingers did you
question a little bit whether or not yes
as you're reading it you go like uh okay
I'm not really a body parts like because
it's all on paper so you go
I will talk to your dad I will you know
figure it out but then when you watch
Swiss army man you know the way they
think you understand what what they're
trying to do and I think with something
like this you either do it or you step
away because you have to believe that we
need a movie like this that speaks a
different language of us all but at the
core of it is something very human at
the core of it is about family and love
and kindness so you know when you close
that the last page you go like oh my God
I'm not letting go of this and I'm gonna
find somewhere to make it
[Music]
thank you
one of the most special things a great
dress is being in this industry is that
has to be collaborated
it's not just enough
interests us
Alexander McQueen
so it's just like seeing everybody gets
activities
I am I am
doing this yes yes no no only me
[Music]
situation I think it's just taken a
really long time for women to become
um more and more a percentage of
cinematographers I think we're still
only six percent in the world and um
yeah it's we're getting there it's
positive movement there's more and more
women getting into the camera department
but it has been a slow process tell us
about working with Basler and when he
sort of pitched this is at you I mean
you must have been immediately thought
wow this is gonna oh yeah I mean because
I've worked with bears for 20 years and
as soon as he says an inkling of
something happening I'm there because
he's a true Visionary and he cares about
the images and the look of the movie and
the visual language and he's an amazing
collaborator and he always gets together
a great team myself and Catherine Martin
and all the other departments it was
just such a pleasure and for me it's the
most exciting kind of um chance to do
something credible and if you were to
sum up what what you wanted to achieve
with in terms of cinematography this
what was it for you I think the most
important thing for me in the back of my
mind was that the camera danced with
Elvis
thank you very much thank you very much
um
exactly the same time as I said in oh my
God the Shop's amazing I've been
listening to what you're saying and then
suddenly I was like take you in the
business anyway I've gone off already
[Music]
um
thank you
it wasn't clipping on and then
I think it's right now
how's that Jason's all right any break
up on that no perfect there you go
so for me that's really special children
[Music]
um
all right
hello
[Music]
um
hello
unfortunately
yeah
is there anyone here that you wanna meet
so let's go
my new best friends
which is very important information
foreign
[Music]
okay okay
foreign
[Music]
why is this man smiling
we're gonna get something
great amazing
things
[Music]
because I will hold
up
taken out
last night
thank you
okay
um
[Music]
foreign
thank you
is so stress
[Applause]
which is good
ideas
so everybody
TV
are you okay I'm back to my hand I'm
sorry and someone shook it really hard
today how did that happen the dog pulled
me over yeah nothing very glamorous or
anything like that what I'm living here
you're having hold on this is Mars it's
really bad yeah it's it's it's so
exciting I like it like I just keep
saying the same things but that's what
it is it's been really really exciting
the last time they've touched the floor
you know it's been amazing isn't it it
really has yeah and it feels like three
years ago we found you and now you're
everywhere
I'm sorry I don't know what to say for
that is um yeah I've been really lucky
with the job with the jobs that I've
done
not only I've been really proud of but
they've landed with people and people
seem to like it so hopefully I can keep
us going to get it I mean it would be
the greatest honor of my life would be
huge
don't think that's gonna happen because
uh yeah it would mean a huge amount you
could always get an Oscar though in a
few weeks
yeah that would also be pretty amazing
yeah
sorry good yes yes yes good good
um
love them so much
I mean
like it's one of my favorite films of
the year and they are other like the way
that they've conducted that they've
conducted themselves for years and years
and years and then to be on a red carpet
with them and meeting them at parties
and they're everything you expect and so
much more like I admire them all so so
much
yeah absolutely absolutely yeah
absolutely I mean yeah
it's such a huge honor it's
also this this film is something I think
that I'm the most proud of ever
it's a small
Charlotte's a genius and to get to be in
front of that conversation in the lead
out category it really just means a lot
yeah yes
yeah I mean it's that like we shot in uh
hello
yes she has been Monumental in terms of
what she's been saying but we shot in
Turkey
who I know lots of people there from our
time there and it's just it really is
devastating and I think to highlight in
any shape where everyone is just really
important like the death toll is rising
daily so yeah I want more can you say
over then it's like really upsetting I
think
um
is the biggest misconception oh yeah
people I think
things that you know before with the
nominations and stuff like you mentioned
signs I've been asked like when did you
actually find out then I was like yeah
that's when you find out
um
yeah well I'll probably have a better
answer for you when it's all
said and done but that's probably going
to jump into my head first
I'll give you a remark of the five that
I was like this was not what people
expected and yeah
yeah
thanks very much see you later
foreign
that's okay
[Music]
foreign
line
and I can only get occasional ones over
the top before you talk
thank you
getting dressed
[Music]
anymore
anybody
[Music]
so that is
um
[Music]
foreign
but it's not that excuse myself
hello hello Sky News what's up
foreign
[Music]
hello Hi how are you doing very good
very happy happy to be here yeah
you're barely
you know the academy has been very good
to me and I have a very deep
relationship with British culture and
I'm a Gothic boy so you know it is
always a thrill and it's a
highlight for me very important I'm
always nervous
so
yes yes
you know I I think that uh everybody
makes predictions that are based from
observations from the outside it's a
living thing and really when you're
inside it uh you you know that you don't
know
you know I've been there when I've been
the favorite and I don't win I've been
there when it's a surprise from the
inside is the view is very different
well I'm working on it I'm working on
several things at the same time so I
don't know what's next but hopefully
it's in the future
we're still talking
yeah hey
yeah
[Applause]
I actually think business is darker than
this yeah I mean I think Disney
acknowledged and did a lot of darkness
in the stories Bambi uh Snow White
Pinocchio had a beautiful streak of
Darkness I think the man was a genius
and when you think about something
classic and you always you always have
that shrink of Darkness
it's a very personal story for me is I
jokingly say that my autobiography is
Pinocchio and Frankenstein jumped
together
thank you thank you
no
[Music]
um
oh well I heard a I've heard great
stories about actually
a great being of a boy that was a
drummer and was shot and he lost his
nose and his leg and they were made out
of wood and that was one of the things
that created Minogue I haven't heard of
this is a darker ride I guess
I will go any privilege for Tuscany food
is good for you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay
thank you
foreign
inside
insurance
everybody
um
thank you
foreign
yes yeah
um
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
I mean I'm just gonna enjoy myself
um
foreign
[Music]
it's really lovely I actually knew for
quite a while before it was announced
and I forgot that people didn't know so
so people were coming over to me saying
congratulations and I was just going
thank you and I looked like so cool I
look like I was so unfazed but it's
because I've known for months so then I
had to go back and find those people and
go by the way I am phased it's just that
I've known for age and they're like oh
right we did think it was a bit like
yeah thanks
no biggie
um but yeah
excitement levels Rising do you think
um yes I think so how are you feeling
about Bill as well nominated for the
best dancers I really want him to win
when it comes to me I'm like I don't
care who wins I don't really mind the
nominations to win and then when it
comes to Bill I'm like you better win
he's just charm he's you know his charm
his grace he's kindness his generosity
he's just everything all the good things
personified and he's really funny as
well would you do a good Oscar speech he
would do an admit he's so good at
speeches he's he he like gets features
perfectly like he knows the exact right
balance between funny and from the heart
so I really just selfishly really want
to see him do his speech I really want
to know what his Baptist speech would be
okay one question we've got we've gotta
go
really lovely it's so thank God as well
because she's the only thing I keep
looking at her and being like okay I'm
okay because I get very overwhelmed at
these things but having one of your best
friends here it's very strange as well
like we make out like it's really normal
like see you at the rafters and then
we're like wait a sec
this is weird we're in the same category
and we're like best mates it's odd but
we yeah I don't think we think about it
too much because otherwise we both get
freaked out
each other better yeah yeah
thank you thank you
[Music]
foreign
tell you that
you know
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you
so we will be going out live balances
normally pre-recorded it's likely to be
a Minecraft of many surprises to the
field is really wide open despite the
number to films having lots and lots
of things
that's right
now right
[Music]
um
but I
okay
[Music]
yeah
it's a really huge contribution
unexpect
s
someone who is I mean
yeah
yeah yeah
thank you